Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In the 10th century, a time of stark religious divides in Europe, nothing was more authentically multicultural than the business of supplying eunuchs. German warriors on the eastern flank of Christendom, fighting the wars of the Saxon emperors, would take huge numbers of Slavs captive. The most attractive boys among them would then be taken to Verdun, where Jewish surgeons would castrate them,
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在10世纪这个欧洲宗教分歧严重的时代，没有什么比提供太监的生意更具有多元文化色彩了。在基督教世界的东翼，为萨克森皇帝们征战的日耳曼勇士们俘虏了大量的斯拉夫。其中长相最迷人的男孩将被带到凡尔登，那里的犹太外科医生会对他们实施阉割，
removing the testicles and sometimes the penis. The boys would then be transported across the Pyrenees, taken across Spain to the Islamic Emirates in the south, and sold into the palaces there. Welcome to The Rest Is History. With me is Dominic Sandbrook. Dominic, crossing your legs this is quite a painful subject isn't it tom i i enjoyed researching this in a weird way but i
切除睾丸，有时也切除阴茎。随后，这些男孩会被运过比利牛斯山脉，穿过西班牙来到南方的伊斯兰酋长国，并被卖到那里的王宫中。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。和我在一起的是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。多米尼克，听到这儿你都把腿并紧了，这是一个相当痛苦的话题，对吧，汤姆？我，我用一种奇怪的方式享受研究这个，但我也发现之后很难吃下晚饭。嗯，是的，我们吃的是肉丸，所以不太理想，但这里有，有那么多关于这个的骇人听闻的玩笑，然而，当然，它也是，可以说是，一个充满巨大痛苦的故事。确实如此。我想我们之所以能这样做，汤姆，唯一的理由是这种事现在已经不发生了。因为如果这是一个活生生的丑闻，你就不会去做一个半滑稽的播客来谈论它。因为这是一件极其骇人听闻的事情，不是吗？虽然当然，我的意思是，看到积极的一面，嗯，正如我们所将看到的，成为一个太监并不总是百分之百的坏事，
also found it very hard to have my dinner afterwards um yes we had we had meatballs unfortunately so it wasn't ideal but there there are there are so many kind of gruesome jokes on this and and yet of course it is at as it were, a tale of considerable suffering. It is. And I guess it's the only way we can, the only reason we can do it, Tom, is because it doesn't happen anymore. Because if it was a living scandal, then you wouldn't do a sort of semi-humorous podcast about it. Because it is an utterly gruesome business isn't it although of course i mean the the the looking on the positives um as we will see um becoming a eunuch wasn't
而且我发现之后很难吃下晚饭，嗯，是的，我们不幸吃了肉丸，所以不太理想，不过有，不过有，有那么多关于这个的 gruesome 笑话，然而当然，正如它所说，这是一个充满巨大痛苦的故事。确实如此。我想我们之所以能这样做，汤姆，唯一的理由就是这种事已经不再发生了。因为如果这是一个活生生的丑闻，你就不会做一个带有半幽默性质的播客了。因为这是一件极其可怕的事情，不是吗？当然，我的意思是，从积极的一面来看，正如我们所看到的，成为一个阉人并没有
always totally 100 bad news because it was also a way to becoming um a very significant player in the kind of societies where eunuchs had considerable power and so basically what we decided was that we would we did the top 10 weird wars didn't we um and today we're going to do the top 10 eunuchs yes we've got i mean how could how to narrow it down to 10 is an interesting question because there are so many great eunuchs but i think we've got a good selection well at least i have so you've chosen five and i've chosen five um do you want to uh kick off sure well i'm gonna kick off with the eunuch's eunuch as i'd like to think of him the connoisseur's eunuch uh so he's a he's a fellow called baguas so some listeners will know of baguas because
因为这也是一种途径，能够成为那种太监拥有相当权力的社会中的一个非常重要的人物。所以基本上我们决定的是，我们盘点过十大怪异战争，对吧？今天我们要盘点十大太监。是的，我们有，我的意思是，如何将候选人缩减到10个是一个有趣的问题，因为有太多伟大的太监了，但我认为我们有一个很好的选择，好吧，至少我选了，所以你选了五个，我选了五个。嗯，你想，呃，先开始吗？好的，好吧，我要以太监中的太监开始，我是这么认为的，行家里手的太监，呃，所以他是一个叫巴果斯（Bagoas）的人。所以有些听众会知道巴果斯，因为
basically he he ends up being picked up by alex Great. So Alexander has invaded Persia. He's defeated the Persian king, Darius, and he's sort of charging up through the Persian empire. And he ends up near the shores of the Caspian in a place called Harkania. And there, according to the accounts of Alexander's life, he basically sort of picks up this guy who's been a eunuch for Darius now the Persians like almost all ancient empires had eunuchs they had eunuchs in their court and of course a eunuch is is useful to a to an emperor or to a king because they can't have children so they can't they're not really a rival they can't found a dynasty of their own so they are sort of seen as trustworthy in that sense they're sort of good hangers-on and baguas is a is clearly a young man we don't know that much about him um the sources say he was exceptional in beauty and in the very flower of boyhood
基本上他，他最后被亚历山大大帝看中了。所以亚历山大入侵了波斯。他击败了波斯国王大流士，然后他一路向北推进，穿过波斯帝国。最后他在里海海岸附近一个叫希尔卡尼亚（Hyrkania）的地方。在那里，根据关于亚历山大生平的记载，他基本上挑中了这个曾为大流士当太监的家伙。现在波斯人，几乎和所有古代帝国一样，都有太监，他们的宫廷里有太监。当然，太监对皇帝或国王很有用，因为他们不能生育，所以他们不会真正成为威胁，他们不能建立自己的王朝，因此从某种意义上说，他们被视为值得信赖的人。他们是那种很好的随从。巴果斯显然是一个年轻男子，我们对他的了解不多，嗯，史料说他容貌出众，正值青春年少，
and ever we really don't know that much there's one source quintus curtius rufus who writes centuries after the event a roman writer and he says he basically paints a very unflattering portraits of baguette so he's cunning he is sort of feline he he has this big description of him outsmarting a local satrap called orsonese and basically poisoning Alexander's mind against him but it's very hard to know whether that there's any truth in that or whether that's just sort of a Roman projecting this stuff onto Alexandria onto the Persians and onto the Greeks you know this sort of cunning effeminate behavior so you don't know how much prejudice there is in this rather than actual sort of historical source material um there is a good story in
而且说实话，我们真的不知道那么多。有一个史料来源叫昆图斯·库尔蒂乌斯·鲁福斯（Quintus Curtius Rufus），他在事件发生几个世纪后写作，是一位罗马作家，他说，他基本上对巴果斯进行了非常不 flattering（不怎么讨喜）的描绘：他很狡猾，有点像猫科动物，他有一大段描述，讲述他如何智胜当地的总督奥尔索内斯（Orsone），并基本上毒害了亚历山大对他的看法。但很难知道这里面是否有任何真实性，或者这只是罗马人将这种东西投射到亚历山大、波斯人和希腊人身上，你知道，这种狡猾、柔弱的行为。所以你不知道这里面有多少偏见，而不是真正的历史素材。嗯，有一个好故事在
plutarch plutarch says that when alexander was coming back from india um he's just got back this dreadful sort of desert crossing and they have this big sort of basically they have a big piss up where they all get drunk and they all do singing and dancing alexander is absolutely loaded he's completely wasted and bagoas does a bit of singing and dancing and he wins a competition and the macedonian soldiers all shout and roar and tell alexander that he should kiss him and alexander he says says plutarch threw his arms around him and embraced him tenderly now what it's very hard to tell from all this is whether was baguas really alexander's lover as some people think he
普鲁塔克那里。普鲁塔克说，当亚历山大从印度回来时，他刚刚经历了一场可怕的沙漠穿越，他们举行了一场盛大的，基本上是一场豪饮狂欢，所有人都喝醉了，又唱又跳。亚历山大完全喝醉了，烂醉如泥，巴果斯进行了唱歌跳舞，他赢得了一场比赛，马其顿士兵们大声呐喊咆哮，告诉亚历山大他应该吻他，普鲁塔克说，亚历山大张开双臂搂住他，温柔地拥抱了他。现在，从这一切中很难看出，巴果斯真的是亚历山大的情人吗，正如一些人认为的那样，他
may have been was he an interpreter a kind of go-between with the local persian notables who alexander met as he kind of went through the empire um but but what's interesting is that he is a romanticized eunuch so he's most famously the hero of mary reynolds book the persian boy so mary reynolds used him in a great, one of the centrepiece of her great trilogy about Alexander. She uses Bagoas as the narrator. So we're with Bagoas when he's castrated. We see Alexander
可能是吗？他是一个翻译，是亚历山大在穿越帝国时遇到的当地波斯显贵的某种中间人吗？但是，但有趣的是，他是一个被浪漫化的太监。所以他最著名的是玛丽·雷诺（Mary Renault）的书《波斯男孩》（The Persian Boy）中的主角。所以玛丽·雷诺在一本很棒的书里使用了他，这是她关于亚历山大的伟大三部曲的核心部分之一。她用巴果斯作为叙述者。所以当巴果斯被阉割时，我们和他在一起。我们通过他看到了亚历山大。我们如此陪伴着巴果斯。
through this. We are so with Bagoas. Yeah, it's a terrible scene. Any male who has read that sequence, that's definitely you crossing your legs. But it's a really interesting one because Maryary reynolds was of course a gay writer so there's this sort of gay subtext in a lot of her ancient world books and in this the alexander baggis relationship is this sort of great love story isn't it so baggis is the one guy who really everybody else is a
是的，这是一个可怕的场景。任何读过这一段落的男性，绝对都会把腿并紧。但这是一个非常有趣的场景，因为玛丽·雷诺当然是一位同性恋作家，所以在她的大多数关于古代世界的书里，都有这种同性恋的潜台词，而在这一本中，亚历山大和巴果斯的关系统可以说是这样一个伟大的爱情故事，对吧？所以巴果斯是唯一一个真正的人，其他所有人都是一个
conniving politician but baggis is the one person who loves alexander and is true to him and has no agenda and which is obviously completely the opposite of the way that the roman sources said quintus curtius rufus painted him as having this sort of colossal agenda i mean this sort of conniving foppish figure and i guess that that cuts to the heart as it were of the way we we sort of see eunuchs so people you know people had eunuchs because they thought they were reliable because they thought they could be trusted but for a lot of people there is some there was something inherently untrustworthy I think because or unnatural about a eunuch and that explains the sort of the dualism with which they've often been seen in
勾心斗角的政客，但巴果斯是唯一一个爱亚历山大、对他忠诚且没有私心的人。这显然与罗马史料记载的完全相反，昆图斯·库尔蒂乌斯·鲁福斯把他描绘成一个有着巨大政治野心、勾心斗角且矫揉造作的人物。我的意思是，这触及了我们看待太监方式的核心，正如我们所说的那样。所以人们，你知道的，人们用太监是因为他们认为太监可靠，因为他们认为太监可以信任，但对许多人来说，太监身上有些东西本质上是不可信的，我认为是因为太监是不自然的，这就解释了他们在历史资料中经常被赋予的那种二元性。
in historical sources so so mine following up on that is a roman eunuch and we don't know his real name but the name he was given was sporus yeah basically kind of greek for spunk so a kind of very cruel nickname um and he was uh not a slave but a free a free boy um who who got castrated by the emperor nero and he got castrated for a very particular reason which was that nero was was absolutely madly in love with his wife who had the fabulous name papaya sabina uh and and like pete townsend she said hope i die before i get old um this was her great thing she she's basically the kind of archetype for a lot of the myths And like Pete Townshend, she said, hope I die before I get old. This was her great thing. She's basically the kind of archetype for a lot of the myths about luxurious women that get projected onto Cleopatra.
所以，接着这一点，我讲的是一个罗马太监，我们不知道他的真名，但他被赋予的名字是斯波鲁斯（Sporus）。是的，基本上有点像希腊语里的“精液”，所以这是一个非常残酷的绰号。他不是一个奴隶，而是一个自由男孩，他被皇帝尼禄阉割了，他被阉割有一个非常特殊的原因，那就是尼禄疯狂地爱上了他的妻子，他的妻子有一个极其美妙的名字叫波佩亚·萨比娜（Poppaea Sabina），就像皮特·汤森（Pete Townshend）所说的那样，希望我在变老之前死去，这就是她的绝妙之处，她基本上是许多关于奢侈女性神话的原型，这些神话被投射到了克莉奥帕特拉身上。
So she's the one who supposedly bathed in asses. OK. She had a range of cosmetics that was the most fashionable in Rome. So men wanted to sleep with her. Women wanted to be her. She was just tremendously cutting edge. But she died. And the rumour was that she was pregnant with Nero's child. And Nero came in late from the races. She nagged him, Nero kicked her in the stomach, and the resulting miscarriage killed her. We don't know whether that's true, but it's definite that Nero's grief was on a titanic scale. And although marries again a kind of again of a
所以她就是那个据说用驴奶洗澡的人。好的。她拥有一系列罗马最时尚的化妆品。所以男人都想和她睡觉。女人都想成为她。她简直太前卫了。但她死了。传闻她当时怀了尼禄的孩子。尼禄从赛场回来晚了。她唠叨了他几句，尼禄踢了她的肚子，随后流产导致了她的死亡。我们不知道这是否属实，但可以肯定的是，尼禄的悲痛是巨大的。尽管他又一次结婚了，某种程度上又是...
kind of very classy sophisticated Roman woman he missed Poppaea so badly that he wanted to have her physically with him and so he sends scouts out to look for someone who looks like Poppaea and they find this boy who looks like Poppaea so he's clearly incredibly beautiful young boy and that of course is a major reason for for castration is that you halt the the process of puberty um and the romans were very keen on that so there's all kinds of they they would rub um ants eggs on onto the armpits to stop hair from growing um and blood from lam's testicles onto the cheeks to stop the beard from growing but the most brutal thing that you did was was to castrate someone so this is what Nero does and so this this this poor boy gets called Papaya Sabina and gets dressed in Papaya's robes has his
这位罗马女性高贵而又成熟，他极度思念波培娅，以至于渴望她能实实在在地陪伴在自己身边，于是他派遣星探去寻找一个长得像波培娅的人。他们找到了这个长得像波培娅的男孩，他显然是一个极其美貌的年轻男孩。当然，阉割的一个主要原因就是为了阻止青春期的发育，罗马人对此非常热衷。因此，有各种各样的方法，比如他们会把蚂蚁卵涂在腋下以防止毛发生长，把羔羊睾丸的血涂在脸颊上以防止胡须生长，但最残忍的做法还是将人阉割。这就是尼禄所做的事，于是这个可怜的男孩被叫做波培娅·萨比娜，并被穿上了波培娅的袍子，他的
hair done as Papaya had done and wherever Nero goes this this Sporus Poppaea goes and lives out the life not as a eunuch but as a wife and this is so so it's a kind of terrible story it's a terrible story and at one point shortly before Nero um gets toppled and commits suicide Poppaea Sporus gives to Nero an image of Proserpina being abducted by Pluto. So the daughter of the goddess of the harvest being raped by the god of death and taking down into the underworld. And you can see all the kind of psychological resonance there. And then when Nero dies, Papaius Bina is there with him kind of mourns him plays the role of the mourning wife gets picked up by um the the head of the Praetorians um so the imperial guard in Rome very very sinister guy called um Nymphidius Sabinus who claimed to be the illegitimate son of
发型弄得和波培娅一样，内罗走到哪儿，这个斯波鲁斯·波培娅就跟到哪儿，过着一种生活，不是作为太监，而是作为妻子。这真是一个可怕的故事，一个极其可怕的故事。就在内罗被推翻并自杀前不久，斯波鲁斯给内罗送去了一幅普罗瑟尔皮娜被普鲁托劫持的画作，也就是丰收女神的女儿被死神强暴并拖入冥界。你可以看到其中各种心理共鸣。接着，当内罗死后，波培亚·萨比纳也在场，陪伴着他，为他哀悼，扮演着悲痛的妻子的角色，后来被罗马禁卫军的首领——也就是一个非常阴险的家伙尼姆菲迪乌斯·萨比纳——所收留，他自称是...
Caligula um certainly if it was it narrated quite a lot of the unpleasantness. He wants to make himself emperor, and he seizes Sporus as a kind of trophy, as a kind of icon of imperial rule. He falls by the wayside. Galba, a kind of upstanding, upright figure who would have no time with eunuch brides, becomes emperor, but rapidly gets dispatched in turn gets succeeded by a guy called otho who had previously been papaya's husband and nero who got rid of him so that he could marry papaya he then picks up sporus papaya and obviously is transfixed by him her as well he he gets dispatched by a guy called Vitellius who then arrives in Rome
卡利古拉——当然，如果真是这样的话——讲述了相当多的不快。他想让自己成为皇帝，并将斯波鲁斯作为一种战利品、作为帝国统治的一种象征夺了过来。他半途而废了。加尔巴，一个正直、刚正不阿的人物，根本不会理会阉人新娘，成了皇帝，但很快又被消灭，接着由一个叫奥托的人接替，奥托曾是波帕亚的丈夫，而尼禄为了娶波帕亚而除掉了奥托；接着奥托看中了斯波鲁斯和波帕亚，显然也被他（她）深深吸引；他随后被一个叫维特利乌斯的人除掉，维特利乌斯随后抵达了罗马。
declares himself emperor and announces that um his what he's going to do with Sporus is put him into the arena and have him gang raped by presumably by by by gladiators dressed as Hades so to kind of replicate this thing at which point poor Sporus kills himself. Wow. That's not a good story. It's a horrible, horrible story that kind of reminds you of the scale of the brutality and the cruelty that could underpin.
自立为皇帝，并宣布他打算对斯波鲁斯做的事是把他送进竞技场，让那些穿着冥王哈迪斯服装的角斗士们轮奸他，以此来重现这个场景，而就在这时，可怜的斯波鲁斯自杀了。哇。这不是一个好故事。这是一个非常可怕的故事，它让人想起那种能够作为底层支撑的残暴和冷酷的规模。
How old is Sporus, Tom? Do you know how old he is? 12 or 13. I mean, just on the cusp of puberty, I would imagine. So maybe this is a very good moment quickly we've talked about two ancient eunuchs now what is it about i mean in your to you as an ancient historian what is it about eunuchs that made them so attractive to you know ancient courts why do people want them why is there this huge trade in them why are people you know they seem so um they seem so disturbing to us but clearly they weren't disturbing you
斯波鲁斯多大了，汤姆？你知道他多大吗？12或13岁。我的意思是，我想正处于青春期的门槛上。所以也许这是一个很好的时机，我们刚才谈到了两个古代阉人，作为一名古代历史学家，对你来说，阉人究竟有什么特质，让他们对古代宫廷如此具有吸引力？为什么人们想要他们？为什么会有如此庞大的阉人交易？为什么人们……在我们的感觉里，他们似乎……他们似乎让我们感到不安，但显然他们并没有让当时的人感到不安
know weren't disturbing to alexander weren't disturbing to nero what is it about them well i i think we've touched on all of them they they they can't um they can't have sex or get women pregnant they can have sex they can have sex because it's often said eunuchs were great lovers but they can't have sex and have women get get women pregnant so archetypally they are used to guard harems as also as you said they can't have children again they can't have children so they can't they they are seen to be more loyal and as in the case of sporus and probably in the case of baguas i mean we would guess their physical beauty it's it's the idea of of keeping that physical beauty intact and not letting them kind of sprout whiskers or acne or whatever but the one other question that you raised um is that um so you said galba wasn't the kind of person who would have any time for eunuchs
你知道的，这对亚历山大大帝来说并不困扰，对尼禄来说也不困扰，那它们究竟是怎么回事呢？嗯，我想我们已经触及了所有这些原因。它们、它们、它们不能，嗯，它们不能发生性行为或让女人怀孕。它们是可以发生性行为的，它们是可以发生性行为的，因为人们常说太监是出色的情人，但它们不能在发生性行为的同时让女人生、让女人怀孕，所以在原型上，它们被用来守卫后宫。正如你所说，它们也不能生育，同样，它们不能生育，所以它们不能、它们被认为更忠诚。正如斯波鲁斯（Sporus）的情况，可能还有巴戈阿斯（Bagoas）的情况，我的意思是，我们可以猜测它们的身体美，这、这是关于保持这种身体美完整，不让它们长出胡须、青春痘或别的什么的想法。但你提出的另一个问题，嗯，是，嗯……所以你说加尔巴（Galba）不是那种会把时间浪费在太监身上的人。
so are there always people who think there's something wrong about them who are who are opposed on principle to eunuchism if that's a word yeah in the in the roman court definitely in the roman court they're seen as as sinister and oriental yeah um not the kind of thing that an upstanding roman would have and so they become um kind of counter-cultural for people who want to push things out so so mycenas augustus's um great advisor he's flanked by two eunuchs and this is a kind of mark of his willing that you know he's kind of tweaking the noses of the respectable establishment so janus who is um tiberius's consigliere um he has a he has a um a eunuch called boy Toy. Oh, my God. Obviously, you can see why he's... And again, he's...
所以，是否总有人认为他们有什么不对劲，从原则上反对阉人制度（如果这是一个词的话）？是的，在罗马宫廷里绝对是这样。在罗马宫廷里，他们被视为阴险和东方化的象征，嗯，这不是一个正直的罗马人会做的事，因此他们变成了某种反主流文化的东西，专属于那些想要打破常规的人。因此，奥古斯都伟大的谋士梅塞纳斯（Maecenas），他身边跟着两个太监，这是一种他意愿的标志，你知道的，他有点在挑衅那些正派的建制派。因此，提比略（Tiberius）的心腹塞扬努斯（Sejanus），他有一个、他有一个太监名叫“玩具男孩”。哦，天哪。显然，你可以看出为什么他……而且，他也是……
You know, it's kind of pushing the edge out, I guess. But in due course, as we will see when we come to my next choice, actually, the Roman world becomes more habituated to eunuchs. But what's your next? OK, so I'm going far forward in time. Am I allowed to... We're sort of ranging about chronologically, aren't we?
你知道的，这有点在挑战底线，我想。但在适当的时候，正如我们接下来谈到我的下一个选择时将看到的，实际上，罗马世界变得更加习惯于太监了。但你的下一个选择是什么？好的，所以我要把时间大幅向前推。我被允许这样做吗？我们是在按时间顺序随意跳跃，对吧？
So I'm going to rush forward, because this isn't somebody who is a sort of institutionalised eunuch. He's somebody who's a bit of a one-off. He's called Thomas H. Corbett, Boston Corbett. So I know you know this story, Tom, because we were talking about it earlier. So he is the man, basically, to cut the long story short, he's the man who shoots and kills John Wilkes Booth the assassin of Abraham Lincoln and so this is a different kind of unit because
所以我要快进到未来，因为这不是那种体制化的太监。他是一个有点独一无二的人。他叫托马斯·H·科比特（Thomas H. Corbett），波士顿·科比特（Boston Corbett）。所以我知道你知道这个故事，汤姆，因为我们之前谈过。所以他这个人，简而言之，他就是那个开枪打死亚伯拉罕·林肯的刺客约翰·威尔克斯·布斯（John Wilkes Booth）的人。所以这是一个不同类型的太监，因为
this is somebody who is basically auto-castrated rather than had it done to him as a boy so it's quite a sad story this actually they're all sad stories in their way but this is a particularly disturbing story I think because he's clearly mad He's born in London in 1832. He moves to New York. I mean, he's as mad as a hatter because he is a hatter. I mean, that expression comes from the fact that a hatter's worked with a substance called mercury nitrate, and mercury nitrate would basically poison you,
这是一个基本上是自己阉割自己，而不是在小时候被人阉割的人，所以这其实是一个相当悲伤的故事。在某种程度上，它们都是悲伤的故事，但我认为这是一个特别令人不安的故事，因为他显然疯了。他1832年出生于伦敦。他搬到了纽约。我的意思是，他疯得像个帽匠，因为他本来就是一个帽匠。我的意思是，这个俗语源于帽匠使用一种叫硝酸汞的物质工作，而硝酸汞基本上会使你中毒，
and it could make you mentally ill. And that seems to be what happened to boston corbett so he he moves to boston which is why he gets the name the nickname boston um his wife has died in childbirth and that clearly has sort of pushed him over the edge in some way because he becomes a street preacher and basically what we would now think of as he's a kind of religious maniac really he's a sort of fundamentalist he he's he believes god is talking to him he believes the world is sinful and all this stuff and in 1858 he's walking down the street in boston when he's accosted by two prostitutes and we don't know exactly what happened but we know that
并且会让你精神失常。这似乎就是波士顿·科比特身上发生的事情。所以他搬到了波士顿，这就是他得到“波士顿”这个绰号的原因。他的妻子死于难产，这显然在某种程度上把他逼到了崩溃的边缘，因为他成了一名街头传教士，基本上就是我们现在所认为的那种宗教狂人。他是一个原教旨主义者，他相信上帝在对他说话，他相信世界是有罪的等等。1858年，他在波士顿街头行走时，遭到两个妓女的搭讪，我们虽然不知道具体发生了什么，但我们知道
he found the encounter very disturbing in some way clearly presumably he was aroused or he was tempted or something so he goes back and and he reads his Bible for a bit. And he reads the bit in, I think, Matthew, where it's like, if your eye offends you, pluck it out. If your hand, you know, cut it off. And he thinks, well, obviously the thing to do is castrate myself. And he does with a pair of scissors. Don't listen to this while you're eating your dinner.
他发现这次遭遇在某种程度上非常令人不安，显然他当时被撩拨了，或者受到了诱惑什么的，于是他回去读了一会儿《圣经》。他读到了我记得是在《马太福音》里的那段话，大意是：如果你的眼睛冒犯了你，就把它挖出来；如果你的手，你知道的，就把它砍掉。他心想，显然该做的事就是把自己阉了。于是他就用一把剪刀这么做了。吃晚饭的时候可别听这段。
He basically cuts himself open and takes his testicles out. Then, unbelievably unbelievably he goes and he goes out for a meal he goes out to like a restaurant or something and then he goes to a prayer meeting and only after that does he check into does he basically go to hospital and say oh by the way i'm i'm hideously mutilated can you please sort me out so after that he joins the union army um he's he's incredibly insubordinate he's always in trouble because because of his religious mania basically so when people give him orders he often disobeys them because he says god's given him a different order he's always completely saying he doesn't want to obey his officers because they're swearing or
他基本上把自己割开，把睾丸掏了出来。然后，难以置信的是，他居然出去吃了一顿饭，去了一家餐馆什么的，接着又去参加了一个祷告会。直到那之后，他才去医院，说：‘哦，顺便说一句，我被严重阉割了，能帮我处理一下吗？’在那之后，他加入了联邦军队。他极其不服从上级，总是惹麻烦，这基本上是因为他的宗教狂热。所以当人们下达命令时，他经常抗命，因为他说上帝给了他不同的命令。他总是公然表示不想听从军官的指挥，因为他们在说脏话或者
drinking or something um and he is the guy is he's among the people who are sent to capture john wilkes booth and they're told bring him back alive don't shoot him he shoots him so he gets in trouble for that but he then sort of trades on that he goes around you know we were talking in our wild west podcast about the about the media in america in this period and he's a celebrity he goes and gives talks as the man who shot John Woods Booth. But that all sort of ends in tears. He becomes a hatter again. He becomes a preacher.
喝酒什么的。他是被派去抓捕约翰·威尔克斯·布思的人之一，当时他们接到指示要把他活捉回来，不要开枪打死他，结果他却把布思击毙了。因此他惹上了麻烦，但他随后利用了这一点到处吹嘘。我们在狂野西部播客里聊过这一时期的美国媒体，他成了名人，到处去演讲，自称是“枪杀约翰·威尔克斯·布思的人”。但这一切最终以悲剧收场。他又成了制帽匠，后来又成了传教士。
He basically becomes a sort of itinerant madman. At one point, he's the porter of the Kansas House of Representatives, a job he loses because he's sort of madly muttering to himself and waving a gun around. And even in Kansas, which is kind of lawless in those days people think this is a bit much and this is not ideal kind of porter behavior um and we don't really know people think he probably died in a forest fire in minnesota as a sort of sort of loony it's a very very sad and strange story um but he so that's another reason for cast for castration isn't it is religious mania yeah i think those are the two regions i i've got more religious maniacs to
他基本上变成了一个流浪的疯子。有一次，他是堪萨斯州众议院的门房，后来因为疯疯癫癫地自言自语还挥舞着枪而被解雇了。即便是在那个时代比较法外之地的堪萨斯州，人们也觉得这有点过分了，这可不是理想的门房行为。我们其实并不知道具体情况，人们猜测他大概是在明尼苏达州的一场森林大火中像个疯子一样死去了。这是一个非常非常悲伤且离奇的故事。所以，这也是选择阉割的另一个原因，那就是宗教狂热。是的，我认为这就是那两个原因。汤姆，我还有更多的宗教狂热分子要
come tom i've got more i've got i've got all the religious maniacs you might want so so there were there were um the priests of kibble the mother goddess right thought that they were called by the mother goddess to castrate themselves and so this was very much their gimmick was that they would castrate themselves and then roam the streets waving their their testicles in in the air so that that was very much that was all part of the fun yeah um but i i've also got someone who reputedly castrated himself um because he he felt that um christ wanted it um and that is the great church father origin ah yes yeah I think the the most brilliant of the church fathers born in in Alexandria in the late second century AD
登场，我还有好多呢，你想了解的宗教狂热分子我应有尽有。所以，当时有……比如母神西布莉的祭司们，对吧？他们认为自己是受到母神召唤而进行自我阉割的。所以这成了他们的标志性把戏：自我阉割，然后在街上游荡，把他们的睾丸在空中挥舞。这基本上就是全部乐趣所在。不过，我也听说过另一个人，传说他之所以自我阉割，是因为他觉得基督希望他这么做，而这个人就是伟大的教会之父奥利金。
and he more than anyone else fuses these two great traditions that you have in Alexandria of the Greek and the Jewish so he's a brilliant philosopher he's completely schooled in Hebrew scripture and he kind of blends the two to to create the kind of basically Christian theology so essentially he's the as much as anyone does he's the father of Christian theology so he's a brilliant brilliant man and the story is according to Eusebius who is a Palestinian bishop in the early fourth century a biographer of Constantine the great author of the first history of the Christian church great admirer of origin and he says that origin castrated himself and he did this again because he was mandated by his understanding of scripture and the verse in scripture it came from matthew and it was um
是的，没错。我认为他是教会之父中最才华横溢的一位，公元二世纪末出生在亚历山大港。比起任何人，他都更完美地将亚历山大的希腊传统和犹太传统这两大伟大传统融合在了一起。他是一位才华横溢的哲学家，精通希伯来经文，他将两者结合起来，创立了基本上属于基督教神学的东西。所以从根本上说，他是基督教神学的奠基人（如果非要说有谁的话）。他是个绝顶聪明的人。根据优西比乌斯的说法，情况正是如此。优西比乌斯是公元四世纪初的一位巴勒斯坦主教，也是君士坦丁大帝的传记作家、第一部基督教教会史的作者，同时还是奥利金的极大崇拜者。他说奥利金对自己实施了阉割，而他这么做同样是因为受到他对经文理解的驱使，经文中的那句经文出自《马太福音》，内容是……
this line for there are eunuchs who have been so from birth and there are eunuchs who have been made eunuchs by others and there are eunuchs who have made themselves eunuchs for the sake of the kingdom of heaven let anyone accept this who can so that's matthew 19 12 and supposedly origin was influenced by this to castrate himself now did he really very very serious doubts about this so origins supposedly told a bishop in alexandria a guy called demetrius that he'd done this in strictest confidence and this is where eusebius got it from but there are two reasons to doubt this account the first is that Demetrius and Origen had an enormous bust up um Demetrius felt that that um that Origen was kind
“因为有生来是阉人，也有被人阉的，并有为天国的缘故自阉的。这话谁能领受，就可以领受。”这是《马太福音》第19章第12节。据说奥利金就是受此启发而把自己阉了。不过，这真的是这样吗？对此存在非常非常严重的怀疑。据说奥利金曾在亚历山大港向一位名叫德米特里乌斯的主教极其保密地透露过他做过这事，优西比乌斯就是从这里得知这一消息的。但有两个理由可以怀疑这种说法：第一，德米特里乌斯和奥利金曾有过一次巨大的闹翻。德米特里乌斯觉得奥利金有点
of insubordinate was too clever for his own boots was was kind of getting above himself so you could absolutely imagine that this is the kind of snide yeah uh malevolent backstabbing so he's so demetrius wouldn't be saying it in praise he would be saying this man literally has no balls basically supposedly he initially approved it and then just changed his mind right but the other reason to doubt it is that um origin actually wrote a huge commentary on matthew and he wrote on this very verse and he said don't do it but he could be speaking from experience he might say I've made a terrible mistake don't don't be my mistake yeah he could be because he says that people have castrated themselves and that these people have you know
过于目中无人、自作聪明、有点飘了。所以你完全可以想象，这是一种尖酸刻薄、恶意中伤、背后捅刀子的行为。德米特里乌斯说这话可不是为了赞美他，而是在说这个家伙字面意义上就是个太监。据说德米特里乌斯最初对此表示赞同，后来却改变了主意。然而，怀疑这一说法的另一个原因是，奥利金实际上写过一篇关于《马太福音》的大型注释，他在其中专门谈到了这节经文，并劝诫人们不要这么做。不过，他也许是在现身说法，他可能会说：“我犯了个可怕的错误，千万别学我。”他完全有可能是这个意思，因为他提到过有人进行了自我阉割，而这些人……
people who've castrated themselves um people get repro you know they draw approach they draw scandal upon themselves so he might have been talking about himself personally i doubt it so perhaps i shouldn't have included him but he's very famous as someone who might be right yeah he's my choice we've got time for one more i think so i think what's really interesting about a lot of these eunuchs tom is that um they're shrouded in so much mystery aren't they and that's what makes them fascinating because people project onto them and they they you know what they want they see what they want to see and and my next example is a great example of that because he's a man called Samson Rowley and a few listeners on on Twitter said are you going to talk about Samson Rowley but of course the problem with him is we don't really know very
那些自我阉割的人……人们会谴责他们，他们给自己招来了非议和丑闻。所以他当时可能是在谈论他自己，但我对此表示怀疑。也许我不该把他列入其中，但他作为这样一个可能存在的人非常有名。对，他是我的选择。我想我们还有时间讲最后一个。我觉得关于其中很多太监，最有趣的一点是，汤姆，他们身上笼罩着太多的神秘色彩，不是吗？正是这一点让他们如此迷人，因为人们会将自己的期许投射到他们身上，他们看到了自己想看到的东西。我的下一个例子就是一个很好的证明，因为这个人叫萨姆森·罗利。Twitter上的几位听众曾问过：“你们会谈到萨姆森·罗利吗？”但当然，关于他的问题在于我们其实并不了解太多……
much so what we know about him is he's a Norfolk merchant's son in the 16th century he's probably from Great Yarmouth his father came from, so they're clearly involved in the kind of mercantile world. And in 1577, Samson Rowley is on the ship called the Swallow, which seems to be captured by the Ottomans. And I assume a lot of the people on the ship were killed, but he wasn't. He's castrated and turned into a eunuch and he converts to islam he takes the name hassan agha and he pitches up in algiers which is the sort of outlying
所以我们对他的了解是：他生活在16世纪，是一个诺福克郡商人的儿子，可能来自大雅茅斯，他的父亲也出身于此，所以他们显然卷入了某种商业世界。1577年，萨姆森·罗利在一艘名为“燕子号”的船上，这艘船似乎被奥斯曼人俘获了。我猜船上的许多人都被杀了，但他没有。他被阉割并变成了太监，随后皈依了伊斯兰教，取名哈桑·阿加，并出现在阿尔及尔——这可以说是奥斯曼帝国的某种外围
uh possession basically of the ottoman empire and he becomes um the sort of treasurer of Algiers. So he basically rises through conversion and through becoming a eunuch. This is not uncommon. So the chief executioner of Algiers was a butcher from Exeter, at the same time a man called Absalom. And in fact, the man who was running Algiers, who was Uluch Ali or Occhiali in Italian was a former galley slave from southern Italy so that shows you something
属地。他成为了阿尔及尔的财务官。所以他基本上是通过皈依和阉割实现了晋升。这并非罕见现象。当时的阿尔及尔首席刽子手是一个来自埃克塞特的屠夫，名叫阿布沙洛姆。事实上，当时统治阿尔及尔的人——也就是意大利语中的乌卢奇·阿里或奥恰利——曾是南意大利的一名 galley slave（桨手奴隶）。这向你展示了奥斯曼帝国的运作方式：
about how the Ottoman Empire worked that basically you could be captured and imprisoned and then work your way up so clearly there's a premium on people with experience from elsewhere and you would think that Rowley the reason Rowley becomes the treasurer is because he's a merchant because he knows his way around a ledger I mean he's lost his his genitals but he knows still knows how to sort of balance a budget so he becomes the treasurer there is a picture of him that shows him with a white turban very pale skin and kind of rosy cheeks although having said that because he's castrated at a late stage, it's unlikely that it would have had a massive impact on his appearance.
基本上你可能被俘虏并投入监禁，然后一路奋斗上去。所以显然，拥有外地经验的人非常抢手。你可能会认为罗利之所以能成为财务官，是因为他是个商人，因为他精通账目。我是说，他失去了生殖器，但依然知道如何平衡预算。因此他成了财务官。有一张他的画像，画中他缠着白色头巾、皮肤非常苍白、双颊泛红。话虽如此，由于他是在较晚的时期被阉割的，这不太可能对他的外貌产生巨大影响。
So this is probably, again, a bit more projection. But there's one source that people always pick up on, which is basically a letter from Elizabeth I's ambassador to him to say, can you use your influence to release some slaves? So he's often used as a kind of window into this relationship between elizabeth and the ottomans because of course they both hate the catholic powers so this was a period when elizabethan england was sort of trying to forge some links with the mediterranean global england exactly global yes exactly um but that's really
所以这可能又是一层投影。不过有一个资料来源是人们总是经常提起的，基本上就是伊丽莎白一世的大使写给他的一封信，请求他利用自己的影响力释放一些奴隶。因此，由于他们都痛恨天主教势力，他经常被用作了解伊丽莎白与奥斯曼帝国之间关系的窗口。当时伊丽莎白时期的英格兰正试图与地中海世界建立一些联系，可以说是全球化英格兰。没错，全球化，完全正确。但这就是……
all we know of samson Rowley so a lot of people find him a fascinating figure particularly now because of course people are very into historians are very interested now in kind of interest in sort of wacky multicultural links and in links between England and the Islamic world and so on so he sort of looms much larger as a historical figure now probably than he's ever done before. But we know so little about him. And there is this sort of story. I haven't really seen any sources for it. At some point, people said to him, why don't you come back to England?
我们对萨姆森·罗利所了解的全部了。所以很多人觉得他是一个迷人的人物，尤其是现在，因为历史学家们现在对各种奇特的多元文化联系、英格兰与伊斯兰世界之间的联系等等非常感兴趣。因此，作为一个历史人物，他在现在的形象可能比以往任何时候都要高大。但我们对他的了解实在是太少了。而且流传着这样一个故事——我其实没怎么见过相关的历史出处——曾有人对他说：“你为什么不回英格兰呢？”
Why don't you come back to Great Yarmouth? And he said, you know, I'm fine. I'm in Algiers. I'm the chief treasurer. Why do I want to run a warehouse in Great yarmouth when i could be a very important person in north africa with this nice climate and eating tagines or whatever he's whatever he's up to that's part of the story that clearly goes all the way back to the 10th century and before because the the scale of the slave trade of people from europe going into the the islamic world is is absolutely enormous again perhaps something that we could
“你为什么不回大雅茅斯呢？”他说：“你知道的，我挺好的。我在阿尔及尔，我是首席财务官。当我在北非能成为一个气候宜人、吃着塔吉锅之类美食的大人物时，为什么还要回大雅茅斯去经营一个仓库呢？”无论他当时在做什么，故事的一部分显然可以追溯到10世纪甚至更早，因为欧洲人流向伊斯兰世界的奴隶贸易规模绝对是巨大的。这也许又是我们可以
do a future podcast on. But Tom it's an interesting question with him would you rather I mean it's interesting I wonder would he rather have kept his genitals and stayed in Norfolk yes it's an impossible question. It's a question for Alan Partridge surely
在未来制作播客的主题。不过，汤姆，关于他有一个有趣的问题：如果是你，你愿意……我是说这很有趣，我想知道他是否宁愿保留生殖器并留在诺福克？是的，这是一个无法回答的问题。这绝对是个适合艾伦·帕特里奇的问题。
yes well I think on Alan Partridge, surely. Yes, well, I think on that part, time for a break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip,
是的，好吧，说到艾伦·帕特里奇，确实如此。好的，我想关于这一部分，该休息一下了。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐至死》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量八卦的固定去处，
and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment, and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History
在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场演出门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisent_entertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史至死》（The Rest Is History），
on the very squirm-worthy subject of eunuchs. Now, we've done five of our top ten eunuchs, and Tom Holland, as always, has a eunuch up his sleeve. Tom, who's your eunuch? Never knowingly without a eunuch. Yes, so mine is, I think, one of the most remarkable figures in Byzantine history. So this is the Roman Empire. It's in the east, centered in Constantinople. Rome and Italy has fallen to the barbarians.
今天我们要探讨的是令人尴尬的太监主题。现在，我们已经盘点了我们心目中的前十大太监中的五个，而汤姆·霍兰一如既往地袖子里藏着一个太监。汤姆，你的太监是谁？我从来不会在没有太监的情况下出场。好的，所以我的这个人，我认为是拜占庭历史上最了不起的人物之一。这里指的是罗马帝国，它位于东方，以君士坦丁堡为中心。罗马和意大利已经沦陷于蛮族之手。
In Constantinople, the emperors there are not very happy about that. And the greatest Roman emperor of the 6th century, Justinian, has his eyes on on the reconquest of italy um and the guy who leads that is is belisarius who isn't a eunuch um but therefore could potentially be a danger to the uh to the emperor and so the guy who takes over from belisarius as the uh the guy who's in charge of bringing italy back into the roman empire is a eunuch um a a guy of armenian extraction called narses and we don't really know how or why he became a eunuch but we know that he is essentially kind of again very influential figure
在君士坦丁堡，那里的皇帝对此感到很不高兴。公元六世纪最伟大的罗马皇帝查士丁尼将目光投向了对意大利的收复。领导这一行动的人是贝利撒留，他并不是太监，因此对皇帝来说可能潜在地构成危险。因此，接替贝利撒留负责将意大利重新纳入罗马帝国版图的人是一名太监——一个名叫纳尔塞斯的亚美尼亚血统男子。我们其实并不清楚他究竟是如何或为何成为太监的，但我们知道他基本上再次成为了君士坦丁堡国库中一个非常具影响力的人物。
in the in the kind of in the treasury of constantinople this idea that essentially the treasury should be run by eunuchs i think is a kind of interesting one that perhaps i'm trying to think of recent chances of exchequer philip hammond george osborne gordon brown but narcisse narcisse plays um a role in the kind of the great sports scandal um of of constantinople when um in 532 when the uh two rival teams in the um in the hippodrome um the blues and the greens rival factions supporting different charity teams there's a spectacular riot and the riot basically ends up burning down central constantinople and they can do this because freakishly the blues and the greens have teamed up normally they're inveterate enemies and narses plays a role in um getting the
这种国库应该由太监管理的想法，我认为是一个挺有意思的现象。我在试着想想最近的英国财政大臣——菲利普·哈蒙德、乔治·奥斯本、戈登·布朗……但纳尔塞斯在君士坦丁堡的那场宏大的体育丑闻中扮演了角色。那是公元532年，竞技场的两支敌对车队——支持不同赛马团体的“蓝党”和“绿党”——爆发了惊人的暴乱。这场暴乱最终烧毁了君士坦丁堡市中心。他们之所以能做到这一点，是因为蓝党和绿党竟然反常地结成了同盟，而他们平时可是死敌。纳尔塞斯在促使……
blues back on side so that then justinian soldiers can slaughter the greens and that's the kind of classic role of the kind that you get in game of thrones with varys um the guy operating behind wheeling dealing offering bribes, pulling strings. Varys certainly as played in the TV drama is a large man. Narcisse was a thin man, very thin and slight, but it turns out he becomes a brilliant general. And he goes toaly after belisarius has been called back at a kind of incredible age i mean he's he first goes there when he's in his 60s does incredibly well gets recalled then goes out in his 70s and he goes there because all the other generals have failed against the a gothic king who's refusing to accept defeat marseilles defeats him um he then defeats a bunch of franks um who who very
蓝党重新归附方面发挥了作用，好让查士丁尼的士兵能够屠杀绿党。这就像我们在《权力的游戏》中从瓦里斯身上看到的那种经典角色：一个在幕后操纵、长袖善舞、提供贿赂、拉拢关系的人。电视剧里扮演的瓦里斯无疑是个胖子，而纳尔塞斯却是个瘦子，非常消瘦纤细。但事实证明，他成了一名出色的将军。在贝利撒留被召回后，他以惊人的高龄前往意大利——我是说，他第一次去那里时已经60多岁了，表现极其出色；被召回后，他又在70多岁时再次出征。他之所以去，是因为所有其他将军在面对一位拒绝接受失败的哥特国王时都失败了。纳尔塞斯击败了他，
contemptuous of him um as a as a eunuch um and he then uh he celebrates rome's last triumph so he takes his prisoners and his gold and his loot through the streets of rome and this is the very last guy to do what a way for Rome to to bow out. I know and and I mean imagine in the age of Nero saying that the last Roman who will celebrate a triumph will be a eunuch no one would have believed it and he then organizes Italy very very effectively and efficiently for 12 years um right the way into his late 80s um justinian dies a new emperor comes and it said that the the empress is very contemptuous of him um and sends him a golden spindle and says because you're a eunuch you shouldn't be organizing you know armies and states and things you should come home and
随后又击败了一群对他的太监身份极为蔑视的法兰克人。接着，他庆祝了罗马的最后一次凯旋：他带着战俘、黄金和战利品穿过罗马的街道。这就是最后一个做到这一点的人。罗马以这种方式谢幕，真是别有一番滋味。我知道。想象一下，在尼禄的时代，如果有人说最后一个庆祝凯旋的罗马人将是一个太监，谁会相信呢？随后，他在长达12年的时间里，非常有效且高效地将意大利组织得井井有条，一直干到他80多岁高龄。查士丁尼去世了，新皇帝登基。据说新皇后对纳尔塞斯极为蔑视，送给他一个金纺锤，并说：“既然你是太监，就不该去组织军队和国家之类的事情，你应该回家去。”
organize uh the the women weaving and narses it is said um says, well, well, I will weave you such a tapestry as you will never unpick. And the story is that his last dying thing is to send a message to the Lombards, who are the most terrifying enemy that the Byzantine Empire faces in Italy, who invade in the last months of Narses' life. But that story, I i think is untrue but i think what is true is that the lombards are waiting for narses to die before launching their invasion which is a kind of incredible tribute to him would he have would he have fought himself would he have gone into battle yes he's he's a he's a very very brilliant general and he kind of mixes and matches his his heavy infantry and his pikemen and his cavalry to brilliant effect he's one of the great great generals of antiquity i mean he's kind of you know up there with with hannibal and and he's an amazing
组织呃那些纺织妇女，据说纳尔西斯说，嗯，好吧，我会为你们织一幅你们永远无法拆解的挂毯。这个故事的传说是，他临终前做的最后一件事是向伦巴底人传话，伦巴底人是拜占庭帝国在意大利面临的最可怕的敌人，他们在纳尔西斯生命的最后几个月里入侵了。但我觉得那个故事并不真实，不过我觉得真实的是，伦巴底人一直在等纳尔西斯死后再发动入侵，这对他来说是一种不可思议的致敬。他会，他会亲自迎战吗？他会走上战场吗？是的，他是一位，他是一位非常非常出色的将军，他将重步兵、长枪兵和骑兵完美地结合在一起，效果极其惊人，他是古代最伟大的将军之一，我的意思是，他有点像，你知道的，和汉尼拔不相上下，而且他是一个了不起的
amazing guy wow and of course if he hadn't been a eunuch he would have been a threat to the emperor so he'd never have got that role and well he would and he would never have got into the court of constantinople so he would never have come to the emperor's attention so he's another winner he's another you know he's a winner so losing your testicles can be a huge kind of yes career advantage well my next choice is a man who definitely benefited from losing his testicles so almost all the people well we've talked about ancient people and we've talked about a religious maniac i mean this is somebody who loses his testicles basically for commercial reasons and he's a castrato singer farinelli probably the most famous of all castrato singers now we think of this as a as a must think of this as a very weird
了不起的人，哇。当然，如果他不是个阉人，他就会对皇帝构成威胁，所以他永远不会得到那个角色，嗯，他确实会，而且他永远不会进入君士坦丁堡的宫廷，所以他永远不会引起皇帝的注意，所以他是另一个赢家，他又是另一个，你知道的，他是个赢家，所以失去睾丸可以算是一种巨大的，是的，职业优势。嗯，我的下一个选择是一个绝对受益于失去睾丸的人，差不多所有这些人，嗯，我们聊过了古代的人，我们聊过一个宗教狂人，我的意思是，这是一个基本上出于商业原因而失去睾丸的人，他是一位阉人歌手法瑞内利，可能是所有阉人歌手中最著名的一个。现在我们认为这是一种，一定会认为这是一种非常诡异的
thing but in the 18th century about 5 000 boys a year were castrated in italy um generally by their parents for they often came from poor families and because it was technically illegal the parents would always come up with a pretext they'd say he was being kicked in the groin by a horse or he was born um without them or he's had some you know he's fallen over and had some accident that means they have to be removed and they basically did this because they wanted them to be singers and they wanted them to make a lot of money and that's what happens with farinelli so he comes his father was the capelmeister at andrea cathedral in southern italy he's born in 1705 so he's from quite a well-off family but his father was the kapelmeister at Andrea Cathedral in southern Italy. He was born in 1705. So he's from quite a well-off family.
事情，但在18世纪，意大利每年大约有5000名男孩被阉割，嗯，通常是他们的父母动的手，因为他们经常来自贫穷的家庭，而且由于这在技术上是违法的，父母们总会找各种借口，他们会说他的腹股沟被马踢了，或者他生来，嗯，就没有，或者他经历过，你知道的，他摔倒过，出过什么事故，所以必须切除。他们基本上这么做是因为他们想让这些孩子成为歌手，想让他们赚大钱，法瑞内利就是这样。他的父亲是意大利南部安德里亚大教堂的乐长，他出生于1705年，所以他来自一个比较富裕的家庭，但他的父亲是意大利南部安德里亚大教堂的乐长。他出生于1705年。所以他来自一个比较富裕的家庭。
But his father died when he was young and the family needed money. And he was a good singer. So when he's 12, they have him castrated. So he's not that young. I mean, he's 12 years old. It's kind of like going to choir school, isn't it? It's awful. I mean, there's no anaesthetic.
但他的父亲在他很小的时候就去世了，家里需要钱。而且他唱歌很好听。所以当他12岁时，他们让人把他阉了。所以他其实不算太小。我的意思是，他12岁了。这有点像去唱诗班学校，不是吗？这太可怕了。我的意思是，根本没有麻醉。
I think they'd give kids opium often and they would bathe them in some sort of milk uh but you've got to imagine quite a lot of people probably die in the operation or or suffer hideous infections and things but anyway he doesn't die he's a he's a very good singer farinelli and he uh he becomes famous across italy he's known as illa gatto the boy he sings in palma and milan and places like that he goes off to vienna and then in 1734 he ends up in london and he's a huge hit i mean he's a great star he makes so much money so he makes five thousand pounds a year and i did the calculation you can you can do the calculations online there's a special
我想他们经常会给孩子们一些鸦片，还会把他们浸泡在某种牛奶里，但你可以想象，可能相当多的人在这场手术中死掉了，或者遭受了可怕的感染之类的，但无论如何，他没有死，他是一个，他是一个非常出色的歌手，法瑞内利，他，嗯，他在全意大利闻名，被称为“小男孩”，他在帕尔马、米兰和类似的地方唱歌，他去了维也纳，然后在1734年，他来到了伦敦，他获得了巨大的成功，我的意思是，他是一个超级巨星，他赚了好多钱，他一年能赚5000英镑，我算了一下，你可以，你可以在网上算一下，有一个专门的
sort of website called measuring worth and in terms of earning power that's he's making about 10 million pounds a year um in the so he is a massive massive star he goes to versailles and then he ends up finally in madrid and he's basically the big singing star in madrid and then he retires to bologna when he's had enough and he's visited i mean he's such a celebrity he's visited I mean he's such a celebrity he's visited by Mozart and and Casanova and people like that they make pilgrimages to go and see him he's got this fantastic art collection that he's picked up on his travels so he's got Velazquez Murillo do we do we know what his relationship with his parents was uh no I don't
叫做“测量价值”的网站，就购买力而言，他当时的年收入大约相当于现在的1000万英镑，嗯，所以他是一个巨大的、巨大的明星，他去了凡尔赛，然后最终来到了马德里，他基本上是马德里最红的歌星，接着当他厌倦了这一切后，他退休回到了博洛尼亚，他受到了拜访，我的意思是，他是一个如此名声显赫的名人，他受到了，我的意思是，他是一个如此名声显赫的名人，他受到了莫扎特、卡萨诺瓦和类似这样的人的拜访，他们前去朝拜他，他拥有在旅行中收集的大量绝妙艺术品，所以他拥有委拉斯开兹、牟利罗的作品。我们，我们知道他和父母的关系吗？嗯，我不
know that's a very good question so I don't know whether he he I would assume assume that people wouldn't castrate their children unless they thought they were going to benefit personally from it. So they would probably think that their children would, you know, send money to them if they made a lot of money. And you could make an enormous amount of money as a castrato singer. And the extraordinary thing, Tom, is when do you think the last castrato singer retired? 20th century. Yeah, yeah 1913 so it wasn't actually banned by the papacy i've got it written down somewhere 1903 1903 it wasn't banned until uh the so you know it's still going on throughout the night it's not as fashionable but there i think there was one recording of a castrato singer on youtube so in other words the last castrati were singing at a time when there was recording technology and they had this incredible vocal range and stuff
知道，这是个很好的问题，所以我不知道他是否，我会假设，人们不会阉割自己的孩子，除非他们认为自己能从中获得切身利益。所以他们可能会认为，如果他们赚了大钱，他们的孩子会，你知道的，把钱寄给他们。而且作为一个阉人歌手，你可以赚到海量的金钱。最不可思议的是，汤姆，你觉得最后一个阉人歌手是什么时候退休的？20世纪。对，对，1913年，所以它其实并没有被教皇明令禁止，我在某处记了下来，1903年，1903年，直到嗯，它才被禁止，所以你知道的，它在整个夜晚都还在继续，虽然没有那么流行了，但我记得YouTube上有一段关于阉人歌手的录音，换句话说，最后的阉人歌手唱歌的时代已经有了录音技术，他们拥有这种不可思议的音域等等
i mean that's kind of largely been lost i suppose um but that this that's an interesting thing because it's very different from most of the people we're talking about i mean this is a very cold-blooded economic decision yeah and so i just wonder whether whether um you know whether he felt grateful to his parents or resentful or well here's the interesting thing you can't have kids but you can still make love um and castrati were prized for that reason because they could they could supposedly perform for hours um you know yes and not get you pregnant yeah so it's it is an interesting question i mean a few of us would make that choice for our own children or would wish to have it made for us but did he i mean he was so rich as a result of this so on the subject of having sex and castration
我的意思是，这在很大程度上已经失传了，我想，嗯，但这，这是一个有趣的现象，因为它与我们讨论的大多数人非常不同，我的意思是，这是一个非常冷血的经济决定，是的，所以我只是在想，无论是，你知道的，他是否对父母心存感激还是怨恨，嗯，这里有个有趣的事情，你不能生孩子，但你仍然可以做爱，阉人也正是因为这个原因而备受珍视，因为他们据说可以，可以持续表演好几个小时，你知道的，是的，而且不会让你怀孕，是的，所以这是一个有趣的问题，我的意思是，我们当中很少有人会为自己的孩子做出这种选择，或者希望别人为自己做出这种选择，但他呢？我的意思是，他因此变得如此富有，所以说到性爱和阉割
perfect lead-in to my next um my next choice um which is the great peter abelard ah yes probably one of the most charismatic figures of medieval europe brilliant theologian brilliant rhetorician um described as a man possessed of inestimable cleverness unsurpassed memory superhuman capacity he he described himself as the only philosopher in the world he was the star of the paris schools um people girls swooned over him he was terribly charismatic um men flocked to hear his lectures um so an absolute star and he was employed by one of the canons at Notre Dame, a guy called Fulbert, to serve as tutor to Fulbert's niece, who was an equally brilliant woman called, well, young girl called Eloise. And Abelard, of course, had taken a vow of chastity. Did he let that get in the way of getting off with the incredibly beautiful, incredibly smart, incredibly charismatic Eloise? He did not. And so they had an affair.
这完美引出了我的下一个，嗯，我的下一个选择，那就是伟大的彼得·阿伯拉尔。啊，是的，可能是中世纪欧洲最具个人魅力的传奇人物之一，杰出的神学家，出色的修辞学家，被形容为一个拥有不可估量的聪明才智、无与伦比的记忆力、超人般容量的人，他自称是世界上唯一的哲学家，他是巴黎各大院校的明星，少女们为他神魂颠倒，他具有可怕的个人魅力，男人们蜂拥而至去听他的讲座，绝对的巨星。圣母院的一位教士，一个叫富尔贝尔的家伙，雇他去担任富尔贝尔侄女的家庭教师，这个侄女是一个同样才华横溢的女人，嗯，不，是个年轻女孩，名叫爱洛伊斯。而阿伯拉尔当然已经发誓要保持贞洁。他会让这一点妨碍他和那个难以置信的美丽、难以置信的聪明、难以置信具有个人魅力的爱洛伊斯鬼混吗？他没有。于是他们开始了一段恋情。
Eloise fell pregnant. Abelard sent Eloise off to his relatives in brittany to have the baby he was a boy who was given the brilliant name of astrolabe it's kind of like calling your i suppose i don't know calling your your baby iphone or something i mean it's wonderful name um eloise came back to Abelard in Paris. There's a secret marriage. But by this point, Foolbear and the relatives generally are starting to get a bit Sopranos in their attitude towards Abelard. So Abelard sends Eloise off to a nunnery to keep her safe. He gets attacked in his his own room gets pinned down they get out the pliers and off off come his off come his goo the rest is history so he's left
爱洛伊斯怀孕了。阿伯拉尔把爱洛伊斯送到了他位于布列塔尼的亲戚那里去生孩子，是个男孩，被取了一个绝妙的名字叫“星盘”（Astrolabe），这有点像把你的，我想我不知道，把你的，你的婴儿起名叫“苹果手机”或者别的什么。我的意思是，这是一个绝妙的名字，嗯，爱洛伊斯回到了巴黎的阿伯拉尔身边。他们秘密结婚了。但到了这个时候，富尔贝尔和亲戚们普遍开始对阿伯拉尔采取一种类似《黑道家族》般的态度。于是阿伯拉尔把爱洛伊斯送进了一家修道院以确保她的安全。他遭到袭击，在他自己的房间里被人按倒，他们拿出了钳子，咔嚓一声，咔嚓一声，切掉了他的，切掉了他的黏液，其余的都是历史了，所以他落得个
maimed and and so humiliated by this so traumatized that that essentially this kind of brilliantly gifted public speaker retreats to a monastery in Saint Denis and feels that he has nothing to offer that he can't appear in public but he's still Abelard and so he starts investigating the the traditions of the origins of Saint Denis and disproves them so this doesn't go down very well so he's still up to his tricks and basically he then leaves Saint Denis despite having taken a vow that he'll stay there and he goes back onto the road and again he he essentially he becomes the kind of you know the great star um he he he keeps apart from from Eloise but they they write to each other over the course of of their life
残疾，并且因此感到无比羞辱，备受创伤，以至于这位才华横溢的公开演讲者基本上退隐到了圣丹尼斯的一个修道院里，觉得自己已经无所贡献，无法再公开露面了，但他依然是阿伯拉尔，于是他开始调查圣丹尼斯的历史传统起源并推翻了它们，所以这并没有得到什么好结果，他依然在耍花招，基本上，尽管他曾发誓要留在那儿，但他还是离开了圣丹尼斯，重回四处漂泊的道路。同样地，他基本上成了，你知道的，那个超级巨星，他，他与爱洛伊斯保持距离，但他们在各自的一生中一直保持着书信往来
um Abelard ends up um accused of heresy he gets officially silenced by the papacy um but he remains such a kind of charismatic figure that he gets picked up by the abbot of cluny which is the great monastery in burgundy and the abbot of cluny looks after to abelard until he dies and then when he dies he sends abelard to eloise and the abbot of cluny accompanies the coffin there abelard gets buried and a couple of decades later to eloise and the abbot of cluny accompanies the coffin there abelard gets buried and a couple of decades later when eloise dies um she gets buried alongside abelard and the story is that when they open the tomb to put eloise's body beside abelard's abelard's body he reaches up with his arms and takes eloise in his arms and they oh it's moving it's moving
嗯，阿伯拉尔最终，被指控犯有异端罪，他被教廷正式剥夺了发声的权利，但他依然是一个如此具有个人魅力的传奇人物，以至于他被克吕尼修道院的院长看中了，克吕尼修道院是勃艮第伟大的修道院，克吕尼修道院的院长照顾阿伯拉尔直到他去世，然后在他去世后，他把阿伯拉尔送到了爱洛伊斯那里，克吕尼修道院院长亲自护送棺材过去，阿伯拉尔被安葬了，而在几十年后，爱洛伊斯和克吕尼修道院院长护送棺材过去，阿伯拉尔被安葬了，在几十年后，当爱洛伊斯去世时，她被安葬在阿伯拉尔的身边，传说当他们打开坟墓把爱洛伊斯的遗体放在阿伯拉尔身旁时，阿伯拉尔的遗体伸出手臂，将爱洛伊斯拥入怀中，天哪，这太感人了，太感人了
yeah it is it i mean it's an incredibly a tragic one of the great tragic love stories but he's a bit different from our other eunuchs because he he doesn't owe his identity to his being a eunuch no like nazis his identity gets taken away by it yes yeah so i mean it genuinely is a mutilation, not just of his body, but of his entire career. Yes. He feels himself to be mutilated, humiliated by it. And it's a kind of shadow over his fame from that point on. But of course, it lends this tragic power to his story. Do you think we'd remember him so much if he hadn't had this sort of dreadful ordeal? I think he'd still be remembered by students of of medieval christian thought because he's that significant he's that important
是的，确实如此，我的意思是，这是一个极其悲惨的伟大的悲剧爱情故事，但他和我们的其他阉人有点不同，因为他的身份并非归功于他是一个阉人，不，就像纳尔西斯一样，他的身份是被它剥夺了，是的，所以我的意思是，这确实是一种残缺，不仅是对他的身体，而是对他整个职业生涯的摧残。是的。他觉得自己因此残疾、受辱。从那时起，这就像是他名声上的一片阴影。但当然，这也给他的故事平添了一种悲剧的力量。你觉得如果他没有经历这种可怕的磨难，我们还会这么深刻地记住他吗？我想中世纪基督教思想的研究者们依然会记住他，因为他是如此重要，他是如此意义重大
um but but obviously you know there are all kinds of major christian thinkers in the middle ages that people don't really remember so do people remember saying outsell i mean students of medieval theology do but he's not a household name whereas eloise and abelard i mean you know people write songs about them he's there's still the theme of novels and films and dramas and so yes i think it's it's a crucial part of that anyway um my final choice my final choice but i've gone out i've gone big with my last choice so it's a man called kondraty ivanovich selivanov and he's not merely uh a eunuch, but he's a man who persuades tens, if not hundreds of thousands of other people
嗯，但显而易见，你知道的，中世纪有各种各样重大的基督教思想家，人们其实并不怎么记得，所以人们还记得圣安瑟姆吗？嗯，中世纪神学的学生们会记得，但他并不是一个家喻户晓的名字，而爱洛伊斯和阿伯拉尔，我的意思是，你知道的，人们为他们写歌，他依然是小说、电影和戏剧的主题，所以是的，我认为这是其中至关重要的一部分。无论如何，嗯，我的最终选择，我的最终选择，我的最后这个选择可是玩了个大的，所以这个人叫孔德拉季·伊万诺维奇·谢利瓦诺夫，他不仅仅仅是一个阉人，而且是一个说服了成千上万，甚至数十万其他人
to be eunuchs too. So he lives in the late 18th century in Russia. Russia is, as everybody will know, or at least a lot of our listeners will know, it's a place where weird sects and cults proliferate for centuries. And there was a sect called the Clists, and they were kind of ecstatic flagellants.
也成为阉人的人。所以他生活在18世纪末的俄罗斯。正如大家所知，或者至少我们的很多听众会知道，俄罗斯是一个各种奇奇怪怪的邪教和教派繁衍了几个世纪的地方。当时有一个叫做“鞭身派”（Clists）的教派，他们是一群狂热的苦修鞭笞者。
They went around beating and whipping themselves. And Selivanov, he's a peasant, and he basically leads a breakaway from the Clists. The Clists don't go far enough for him. He claims that he is both the Messiah and he's the former Tsar,eter the third so russia has this great tradition of people pretending to be false dimitries or false this sort of peter the third is the one murdered by exactly exactly so huzzah in the those who've seen the great
他们四处殴打和鞭笞自己。而谢利瓦诺夫是个农民，他基本上领导了一场从鞭身派中分裂出去的运动。鞭身派对他的激进程度还远远不够。他声称自己既是弥赛亚，又是前沙皇彼得三世，所以俄罗斯有着这种假德米特里或假冒其他人的伟大传统，这个彼得三世就是那个被谋杀的，没错，没错，所以看过《凯瑟琳大帝》的人就会懂
so um so kandorati ivanovich selivanov says he's the son of God, he's the redeemer, and he wants lots of followers and he calls them white doves. And he says, basically, we need to break with original sin. And the way to do that is to castrate yourself or if you're a woman, to cut off your breasts. So he basically says your genitals or your sort of sexual organs are their signs of the forbidden fruit that Adam and eve took in the garden of eden and to get back to our sort of pure pre-full state we need to cut them off um and they they do so there are two ways of doing it there's one thing called the lesser seal
所以，嗯，孔德拉季·伊万诺维奇·谢利瓦诺夫说他是上帝之子，他是救世主，他想要很多的追随者，他称他们为“白鸽”。他说，基本上，我们需要与原罪决裂。而做到这一点的途径就是阉割你自己，或者如果你是个女人，就割掉你的乳房。所以他基本上说，你的生殖器官或者说你的性器官，是亚当和夏娃在伊甸园里偷尝的禁果的标志，为了回到我们那种纯洁的、堕落前的状态，我们需要把它们切掉，嗯，他们确实这么做了，有两种切除方式，有一种叫做“小封印”
which i think you just cut your cut your testicles off And the greatest seal is when you cut the lot off. And they do this with knives and with razors and stuff. And then they get a hot iron and they cauterize the wound. If you've had the greatest seal and you're a man, you need to carry a cow's horn through which you can urinate. Now, you would think that this wouldn't really catch on, but you'd be wrong because thousands of people... becomes a big figure in St Petersburg and it gets lots of recruits in St Petersburg in Moscow in places like Odessa so kind of burgeoning growing cities Dostoevsky talks about it by the turn of
我想你只需要切掉你的，切掉你的睾丸，而“大封印”则是指你把所有的东西都切掉。他们用刀子、剃须刀之类的东西来做这件事。然后他们拿来一块烧红的铁块，把伤口烫灼止血。如果你做过大封印而且是个男人，你需要随身携带一个牛角，你可以通过它来小便。现在，你可能会觉得这不会真正流行起来，但你就大错特错了，因为成千上万的人……他在圣彼得堡成了一个大人物，并在圣彼得堡、莫斯科、敖德萨等地获得了大量新信徒，所以可以说是一些新兴的、不断发展的城市，陀思妥耶夫斯基也谈到过它。到了
the 20th century there were probably about a hundred thousand scoptsy as they're called so there's a big cult. The communists suppressed it, and before that, people tried to suppress it. And so some scoptsy were forced into exile. So at the end of the... So at the founder Sieck, there are so many scoptsy in exile in Romania that they basically control the Bucharest cab trade. So if you get in a cab in Bucharest, or indeed perhaps in Budapest,
20世纪之交，大概有大约十万名“阉党”（Scoptsy，俄罗斯极端苦修教派），他们就是这么被称为的，所以这是一个庞大的邪教。共产党人镇压了它，在此之前，人们也试图镇压它。因此，一些阉党成员被流放到国外。所以在……所以在这个教派的创始人时期，有那么多的阉党成员被流放在罗马尼亚，以至于他们基本上控制了布加勒斯特的出租车行业。所以如果你在布加勒斯特打车，或者实际上可能在布达佩斯，
then the chances are it will be driven by a member of the Scoptsy, so a man who's castrated himself. And people do this, you know, in thousands. It's incredibly popular. Yeah, thousands of people do this in a kind of frenzy, believing that this is the route to heaven. And it's only really stamped out during the Soviet Union. I think there's a claim that there are Scoptsy around as certainly as late as the 1940s and there are some people who think there may still be some now they may flourish in some sort of nooks and crannies i mean you get what you people in the church of england worrying that they're a bit bit wishy-washy well by these
那么很有可能开车的是一名阉党成员，也就是一个阉割了自己的人。人们这样做，你知道的，成千上万的人。这极其受欢迎。是的，成千上万的人在一种狂热中这样做，相信这是通往天堂的途径。直到苏联时期，它才真正被根除。我想有人声称，直到20世纪40年代晚期，确实还有阉党成员存在，而且有些人认为现在可能依然存在一些，他们可能会在某种角落和缝隙里繁衍生息。我的意思是，你会看到英国国教会的人担心他们有点软弱无力，好吧，按照这些
standards i mean maybe this would be the way to to reinvigorate yeah it's a it's a robust faith tom there's no doubt about that it's it's demand it's a demanding faith but presumably it has its rewards i can't imagine what they would be but well yeah i mean and imagine if you then realize you've made a terrible mistake that would there's no going back is there especially if you got to the cow horn stage i mean that's a pretty bad so my my last one um we're going to china yeah china is one of the um the the great centers of of world eunuchs um which is back four thousand years so and the the chin emperor um first emperor i mean already they've all the bureaucracy is run by byunuchs. So it's done both as a punishment, but as a way of getting ahead.
标准来看，也许这才是重新焕发活力的方法，是的，这是一种强韧的信仰，汤姆，毫无疑问，它是一种，它是一种要求严苛的信仰，但据推测它也有它的回报，我无法想象那会是什么，不过，好吧，我的意思是，想象一下，如果你随后意识到自己犯了一个可怕的错误，那就没有回头路了，不是吗？特别是如果你已经到了使用牛角的阶段，我的意思是，那真的是相当糟糕。所以我的最后一个，嗯，我们要去中国，是的，中国是，嗯，世界阉人的伟大中心之一，
Yeah. It's a shortcut, as it were. It's like a graduate scheme. It's like a graduate scheme, yes. And my particular one is one we've already talked about, I think, with Michael Wood in the thing we did on China. And it's Zheng He, who lived between 1370 1370 1435 and he's the great admiral who leads the um the voyages of discovery that are sent out in the the early 15th century um he is
可以追溯到四千年前，所以，而且秦朝的皇帝，也就是始皇帝，我的意思是，当时所有的官僚机构都已经由阉人运转了。所以这既是一种惩罚，也是一种出人头地的途径。是的。可以说是一条捷径。就像是一个毕业生培养计划。就像是一个毕业生培养计划，是的。而我特地要讲的这个人，我想我们之前在和迈克尔·伍德合作制作的关于中国的节目中已经讨论过了。他就是郑和，生活在1370年到1435年间，他是那个伟大的海军统帅，率领着
a muslim although a muslim of kind of quite an eccentric kind so when he goes sailing he he he worships the great goddess of the sea okay that's a very unusual kind of he um he got captured um in yunnan which was the last holdout of the uh of the mongol um rulers of china um by the ming who are kind of capturing it back at the end of the 14th century gets captured castrated introduced into the um chinese imperial court has a kind of you know meteoric rise rather in the way that nazis did um and basically gets pointed the admiral of these seven voyages that get sent out across the um the indian ocean all the way to as far as africa so he brings back ostricheses he brings back zebras he brings back a giraffe
15世纪初派遣出去的发现之旅的船队，嗯，他是一名穆斯林，尽管是一种相当奇特的穆斯林的穆斯林，所以当他出海时，他，他崇拜伟大的海上女神。好吧，这是一种非常罕见的类型，他，他在云南被俘虏，云南是当时中国蒙古统治者的最后一个据点，在14世纪末期被正在收复失地的明朝军队俘虏，被俘后遭到阉割，进入了中国宫廷，经历了可以说是，嗯，火箭般的速度崛起，就像纳尔西斯那样，基本上被任命为率领这七次远航深入印度洋直至非洲的舰队司令，所以他带回了鸵鸟，他带回了斑马，他带回长颈鹿，
he also cleans the seas of pirates so he captures the most notorious pirate of the age brings him back to China where the guy's predictably brutally killed the king of C ceylon sri lanka tries to oppose him um bad idea he gets taken back has to apologize um and essentially this is the kind of the great what if that what if china had continued this outward bound approach yeah um it's just on the the just just before the European expansion across the sea. So really, really fascinating figure. Still, he basically gets forgotten in China because these voyages get buried. Chinese imperial policy slams the brakes. It's not necessary.
他还肃清了海上的海盗，他抓捕了这个时代最臭名昭著的海盗，带回中国，那家伙毫无悬念地被残忍处决了，锡兰国王，也就是斯里兰卡，试图对抗他，这绝对是个馊主意，他被带回来不得不道歉，从本质上讲，这就是那种伟大的“如果”——如果中国继续这种向外探索的方法，会怎样呢，嗯，它恰好发生在欧洲海上扩张之前。所以真的是一个非常非常迷人的历史人物。在中国，他基本上还是被遗忘了，因为这些远航的记录被掩埋了。中国帝制的政策猛踩了刹车。这被认为是不必要的。
It goes into reverse. So they get buried. But in recent times, he's become a very significant figure. He is still commemorated to this day in China. The 11th of July is the date that he first sailed in 1405. And the 11th of July to this day is Maritime Day in China. And what happened to him at the end when he got... I mean, did he get back and have a long, happy retirement?
政策发生了逆转。所以它们被尘封了。但在近现代，他变成了一个非常重要的人物。今天在中国依然有人纪念他。7月11日是他于1405年首次起航的日子。而7月11日直到今天仍是中国的航海日。他在最后回来的时候怎么样了？我的意思是，他回来后过上了漫长而快乐的退休生活吗？
He died on one of the voyages and got buried at sea. And on the topic of eunuchs lasting into the present day, do you know when the last imperial eunuch died? I'd probably guess, again, Edwardian, pre-First World War, maybe 1910. 1996. No. Wow. That's a great fact. So that's somebody who but hold on how old was he about 120
他在其中一次航行中去世了，并被海葬了。说到阉人一直延续到现代，你知道最后一个皇太监是什么时候去世的吗？我大概会猜，同样是爱德华时代，第一次世界大战前，也许是1910年。1996年。不。哇。这真是一个惊人的事实。所以那是一个人，但等等，他当时多大？大约120岁
i mean he must have been well he must be one of those chinese people who just eat very healthy so he must have been a boy uh castrated at the imperial court yeah so the question so the question if the to sort of sum all this up i mean a lot of these people these people i suppose can be divided into two categories they're either religious maniacs or they are people who have you know being a eunuch has allowed them to rise to play a part they might not otherwise have been because they're not either because they're a singer or because they're a bureaucrat oh i think there's a third category which is people embroiled in in grotesque love affairs.
我的意思是，他一定，好吧，他一定是个那种饮食非常健康的中国人，所以他一定是个在宫廷里被阉割的男孩，是的。所以这个问题，所以如果要把这一切做个总结，我的意思是，这些人，这些人我想可以分为两类，他们要么是宗教狂人，要么是那些，你知道的，成为阉人让他们能够崛起，扮演他们本来可能无法扮演的角色，要么是因为他们是个歌手，要么是因为他们是个官僚。哦，我觉得还有第三类，那就是卷入荒诞爱情故事的人。
Yes, I suppose so. Yeah. Sporus is not a eunuch, really. He's not treated as a eunuch. He's treated as a bride. Yeah, interesting. So that's weird. And then Abelard is castrated as a punishment.
是的，我想是的。斯波鲁斯（Sporus）其实并不是一个阉人。他没有被当作阉人对待。他被当作新娘对待。是的，很有趣。所以这很诡异。然后阿伯拉尔作为惩罚被阉割。
So that's kind of, I think, a third category, perhaps. But the question then is, you know, through thousands of years of human history, of sort of civilized history, as it were, there have been eunuchs. We are unusual in not having eunuchs. Do you think eunuchs will come back? I don't know. I don't know. That, I think, is an impossible question to answer.
所以这大概是一种，我认为，可能是第三类。但问题是，你知道，在数千年的残酷人类历史中，在某种文明历史中，一直存在着阉人。而我们没有阉人，这反而是不正常的。你觉得阉人会卷土重来吗？我不知道。我不知道。我认为这是一个不可能回答的问题。
I would have thought not, because I can't imagine any circumstance in which international opinion would regard um the harvesting of eunuchs as being in any way except you don't see the eunuch trade you know the way things are going who knows who knows i i can't i can't believe it no i mean because because pretty much every every society would regard it as being beyond the pale now it's a really interesting example of something that was taken for granted, no longer being accepted.
我本以为不会，因为我无法想象国际社会在任何情况下会认为，嗯，“收割”阉人是合乎情理的，除非你看不到阉人交易，你知道事情发展的方向，谁知道呢，谁知道呢，我简直，我简直不敢相信，不，我的意思是，因为几乎每一个，每一个社会现在都会认为这是超越底线的，这是一个非常有趣的例子，说明了曾经被视为理所当然的事情，现在不再被接受了。
Yes, although I suppose we do have much more fluid attitudes to gender and things now, don't we? I mean, people have reassignment surgery and so on and so forth. So the idea of surgery per se or of changing gender is not anathema to us, as it was to our predecessors predecessors yes but eunuchs don't become women well sporus did he no he didn't because he that was what nero wanted okay and he offered prizes for people you know if if there were surgeons who could could do the necessary um surgery and they couldn't um to make him into a woman but couldn't do it and couldn't implant a womb so prepare remains you know as prepare he remains kind of infertile um and what's going on with nero there tom i mean
是的，尽管我想我们现在对性别及相关事物的态度要 fluid（流动的、多元的）得多，不是吗？我的意思是，人们会做重塑手术等等。所以手术本身或者改变性别的想法对我们来说并不是什么十恶不赦的禁忌，就像对我们的前人那样。前人是的，但阉人并没有变成女人。好吧，斯波鲁斯确实变成了，不，他没有，因为那是尼禄想要的，好吧，他为人们悬赏，如果，如果有外科医生能够，能够做必要的手术，而他们做不到，没办法把他变成女人，也无法植入子宫，所以佩罗（Sporus的原名）依然，你知道的，作为一个佩罗，他依然是不孕不育的，尼禄到底在搞什么鬼，汤姆，我的意思是
that's the real of all these issues of all these subjects i mean a lot of these make sense you know you can understand that somebody is is deranged or that somebody is wants money but why does nero want to do that okay well i think i'm not going to answer that because there's there's an exhibition on nero coming up at the british museum and i think it might be a good idea to to see if we could do a podcast on nero great specific great i think that's great so let's let's save that so let's i and i think we've we've run on long enough as it is um could i just put in a plea um where this is going out on thursday the tomorrow so if you're listening to this on thursday when it's dropped so friday 23rd of april st george's day i will be walking 40 miles across london from one end to the other along a sports ley line so i'll be going
在所有这些问题中，在所有这些主题中，我的意思是，很多事情都是说得通的，你知道的，你可以理解某个人是精神失常的，或者某个人想要钱，但尼禄为什么想要那样做呢？好吧，我想我不会回答这个问题，因为大英博物馆马上要举办一个关于尼禄的展览，我觉得如果我们能做一个关于尼禄的播客，那倒是个好主意，太具体了，太棒了，我觉得这太棒了，所以我们把这个留到以后吧，而且我觉得我们已经聊得够久了，我能顺便发个小请求吗？嗯，这个节目是在星期四播出的，也就是明天，所以如果你在星期四节目上线时听到这个，那么星期五，也就是4月23日，圣乔治日，我将沿着一条体育莱伊线（ley line），从一头到另一头，徒步40英里穿越伦敦，所以我将从
from a cricket club in epping to lords to craven cottage to twickenham rugby stadium to a cricket club in chertsey and i'm doing that in aid of three homelessness charities to try and slay the dragon of homelessness dominic you are the saint george of our time i am saint george and um if you felt like sponsoring me that would be hugely hugely appreciated you can find the link if you go to my twitter page at holland underscore tom the pinned tweet there there is a promotional video showing me as a kind of rocky figure getting in training for this um event and there is a link that you could go and pay uh if you wanted to contribute to that so that would be very much busy if not no worries um i hope you enjoyed today's show.
埃平的一家板球俱乐部走到罗德板球场，走到克拉文农场球场，走到特威克纳姆橄榄球场，再到切尔西的一家板球俱乐部，我做这一切是为了支持三家无家可归者慈善机构，试图斩断无家可归这头恶龙，多米尼克，你就是我们这个时代的圣乔治。我是圣乔治，嗯，如果你觉得愿意资助我，那将是无比无比感激的。如果你去我的推特主页，也就是@holland_underscore_tom，置顶推特上有一个宣传视频，展示了我作为一个像洛基那样的人物为这次活动进行训练，那里有一个链接，如果你想为此做出贡献，你可以点击前往，所以如果能得到你的支持那就太棒了，如果不愿意也没关系，我希望你们喜欢今天的节目。
We will be back next week with more podcasts. But until then, thanks very much for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下周还会带来更多播客。但在那之前，非常感谢大家的收听。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击节目文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。